[Música]
bueno pues yo voy a hablar de innovación
lamentablemente tengo que centrar el
tema en uno de los fenómenos delictivos
pues que están a la orden del día que es
el tema de la violencia de género y de
los feminicidios feminicidios homicidios
de pareja
cuando hablamos de innovación es
importante saber el fenómeno es el
fenómeno que estamos hablando si
queremos innovar
tenemos que saber de lo que estamos
hablando tenemos que saber dónde
focalizar nuestras políticas de
prevención entonces yo siempre me gusta
empezar mis conferencias haciendo
respetable reflexionar cuando hablamos
de violencia de género cuando hablamos
de homicidios de pareja de terrorismo
machista violencia de género violencia
contra la pareja estamos hablando del
mismo fenómeno estamos hablando por
supuesto que todos tienen en común como
denominador común la violencia contra la
mujer la violencia contra en este caso
siguiendo jurídicamente la ley orgánica
1/2004 violencia en víctima mujer
victimario hombre existe o haya existido
una relación de afectividad pero
realmente
a veces se utilizan como sinónimos
intercambiables la violencia de género a
los homicidios de pareja piensan ustedes
que es un proceso continuo que la
violencia de género empieza con los
famosos micro machistas micromachismos
va evolucionando violencia psicológica
violencia física violencia sexual y
llega en el peor de los casos al
homicidio o existen hipótesis
alternativas que puedan explicar los
feminicidios digo explicar nunca
justificar el que ha matado al que
asesinado tiene que cumplir pero es
importante saber es importante saber si
es un proceso continuo
es un proceso discontinuo un poco el
enfoque desde el punto de vista en la
innovación que es lo que se trata aquí
es saber si existen otras hipótesis
alternativas a la violencia de género
entonces por eso es importante innovar
en el tema es importante innovar también
sensibilizando aunque es un tema que
lamentablemente está a la orden del día
pero realmente todos los agentes que
trabajan la violencia de género la
violencia de género están sensibilizados
con el tema no me refiero solamente
agentes policiales
sociales agentes educativos hasta los
centros de salud que es donde se
detectan muchos casos estamos
suficientemente sensibilizados de que es
un delito emocional de que la víctima
está denunciando a su pareja con la que
había tenido cosas buenas cosas menos
buenas con la que ha tenido o tiene un
proyecto en común tienen niños tienen
una casa es complicado es complicado es
importante sensibilizar a los actores en
un delito emocional que es un delito
cualitativamente diferente a otros
delitos de acuerdo drogas patrimonio
económicos y eso hay que enseñarlo
entonces en el marco de la investigación
de la innovación hay que pasar de un
enfoque reactivo esperar a que vengan
las víctimas o al centro a poner la
denuncia o al centro de salud a un
enfoque proactivo vamos a ir más allá
vamos a conocer vamos a adelantarnos y
como nos adelantamos al fenómeno
conociéndolo la innovación aquí radica
en
la revisar vamos a ver qué ha pasado
porque un hombre determinado mata a una
mujer determinada en un momento
determinado después de 40 años de
matrimonio o un hombre que termina una
relación se separa se divorcia inicia
una relación sentimental nueva y a los 9
meses acaba con la vida de su nueva
pareja cuando se le pregunta a los
allegados familiares y amigos alguna vez
se había empleado la violencia como
toleraba cómo controlaba la frustración
la ira no era un hombre normal entonces
qué ha pasado qué ha pasado habrá que
saber lo que ha pasado la prevención
tiene que ir perfectamente diseñada y al
ese porque y eso que lo está haciendo
cómo se recopilan yo hice mi tesis en
violencia de género pues leí mucho
muchos por supuesto muchos estudios
muchas investigaciones y siempre me
quedaba la cosa decir los datos que como
como comentaba entre la compañera y de
todos los casos más de un porcentaje no
voy a entrar en cifras un porcentaje muy
elevado muy voluminoso no han denunciado
porque no han denunciado
y en algunos otros casos lo que
socialmente conocido que todo el mundo
conoce mono pues si era un tío normal
era una persona normal y nunca había
tenido antecedentes entonces qué está
pasando los estudios nos informan hay
mucho estudio que habla de variables
sociodemográficas nacionalidad 6 o
variables tecnológicas arma modus
operandi pero el porqué él porque yo
necesito saber el porqué yo desde un
punto de vista policial para diseñar mis
mis recursos materiales y recursos
humanos pero desde el punto de vista de
la prevención las políticas diseñadas
está en los centros penitenciarios no
podemos considerar cometer el mismo saco
una persona que ha matado por homicidios
por compasión a otra persona que sí que
obedece a ese fenómeno seguido de la
violencia de género y otra persona que
bueno que ha matado como los estudios
nos dicen no pues porque se monta una
persona independientemente la violencia
de género
bueno pues estos estudios en innovación
lo que se trata de reflexionar conocer
el fenómeno y para conocer el fenómeno
hay que estudiarlo bien hay que bajar a
la mina hay que entrevistarse eso por
supuesto que implica inversión de
recursos materiales humanos
a parte de tiempo por supuesto pero hay
que saber el por qué las políticas
tienen que estar reitero las cuatro
ideas fuerzas las políticas tienen que
estar diseñadas conociendo el fenómeno
se hizo bueno pues moviéndonos o
siguiendo esta línea de innovación
pensamos bien pues vamos a ver qué es lo
que ha pasado vamos a ver por qué este
hombre ha matado esta mujer en este
momento determinado y creamos un equipo
de revisión de los de los homicidios de
género los feminicidios un poco el
objetivo era saber si la pregunta
general hay es un obedece un fenómeno
continuo los protocolos de valoración de
riesgo
predicen violencia predicen homicidio
estamos hablando de lo mismo que muchas
veces y reitero se utilizan como
fenómenos intercambiables o hay otras
hipótesis porque si hay otras hipótesis
yo necesito saber las para diseñar mis
estrategias operativas con mis fuerzas
policiales oa nivel de campañas de
sensibilización
o educativas o hasta en la sanidad o en
tratamiento en establecimientos
penitenciarios pues en esta línea de la
innovación creamos una
por el equipo de revisión de homicidios
de género el objetivo es un poco a
contestar contestar este tipo de
preguntas y la verdad que hemos tenido
resultados muy interesantes muy
interesantes resultados que responden un
poco a esa y esa hipótesis experimental
no hay otra si hay otras hipótesis
alternativa cómo se creó el equipo de
revisión bueno pues el primero en un
principio creo que nació gracias a gente
innovadora a gente con ganas de trabajar
porque como vuelvo insisto
hace falta entrevistarse con muchísima
gente familiares allegados amigos e
informes psicológicos informes sociales
informes psicosociales todo lo que me dé
información para conocer el fenómeno y
eso hace falta tiempo inversión surgió
en surge en la guardia civil y bueno
pues este proyecto este macroproyecto es
rápido cogió mucha entidad y se pasó a
secretaria de estado para implicar a
otras fuerzas policiales porque es un
fenómeno que se da en todo el territorio
independientemente de clases o de otras
varias sociodemográficas como sabemos
y bueno pues que les puedo contar que
actualmente se han revisado casi 200
casos cuando un hombre ha matado a una
mujer para este estudio hemos contado
con la colaboración por supuesto de
diferentes universidades entre ellas
muchos alumnos de la udima tanto del
grado de criminología como del del
máster de análisis criminal que nos han
ayudado nos han ayudado a entrevistar al
saber el por qué y por supuesto contando
también con la fiscalía de violencia
sobre la mujer con el observatorio y
hemos encontrado resultados muy muy
interesantes y un poco lo que viene a
reforzar la idea es que hay que innovar
y para innovar hay que conocer los
fenómenos de los que se está hablando y
para conocer los fenómenos de los que se
está hablando hay que bajar a la mina y
para bajar a la mina
hay que diseñar hay que contar por
supuesto con gente proactiva con gente
que quiere investigar con gente
sensibilizada en el marco de la
violencia de género o homicidios de
pareja poniendo como denominador común
esa violencia sobre la mujer y como
resultado un poco ya para terminar
para avanzar y tampoco hacer la charla
muy académica simplemente decir que si
existen otras alternativas a la
violencia de género por las que un
hombre mata a una mujer muchas gracias
[Aplausos]